vous vous demandez peut-être ce que veut
faire une première dame lorsqu'elle est
confiné à l'elysée et bien voici la
réponse
elle appelle des stars c'est en tous les
cas ce qu'a décidé de faire brigitte
macron en cette période de covin 19 la
première dame a décroché son téléphone
pour remercier en personne les
célébrités qui se sont mobilisés pour
venir en aide aux hôpitaux et aux
soignants une initiative qui a donné
lieu à une scène à peine croyable
lorsque nabila se retrouve en direct au
téléphone avec brigitte macro mais la
star de télé réalité n'est pas la seule
à avoir eu le droit à son coup de
téléphone
même chose pour calogero qui a
interprété une chanson intitulée on fait
comme si pour soutenir le personnel
hospitalier
mon été
la première dame a également appelé
patrick bruel pour le remercier de ses
nombreuses dédicaces au héros du
quotidien durant les lives instagram et
puis d'un coup il ne t'est qui reculent
l'appel au secours des enfants qu'on
bouscule une bonne façon d'occuper le
temps en pleine période de confinement
imposé mais aussi de continuer à
encourager les bonnes actions de la part
des célébrités comme une folle voilà que
brigitte les après oui gilles verdez
alors deux choses d'abord brigitte pas
quoi il n'a pas de pouvoir politique
mais elle un immense pouvoir humanitaire
et le fait qu'elles se mobilisent comme
ça ça ne peut qu'encourager c'est génial
et ensuite du côté de la ville avec
thomas j'ai échangé avec thomas 1 ils
étaient super contents d'être revenus
dans l'émission ce soir chez ba ba
d'avoir donné et en plus ce qui les a
transportés
vraiment bravo aux 2 alors est ce que
est ce que vous comprenez les gens qui
ont critiqué dabila d'avoir dit que
voilà que brigitte makwala l'annoncé sur
un stade nabil abu comme ça les naturel
est elle était contente elle a mis sur
un stacks vous en pensez un an jean
michel et s'échappèrent faut pas être
hypocrite mois ci avait emmanuel macron
ou riches de mâcon qui m'appelait
évidemment je dirais quand est-ce que
d'enseignants on à la fin de la prison à
vie qui vous appelle c'est normal des
indices et franchement votre critique
souvent mais le geste qu'elle a fait je
m'y attendais pas j'ai trouvé ça va la
gagner des millions ouais et bien c'est
très bien que c'est tout ce que voulait
dire voilà merci à mathieu normal qu'on
le dise pas que de leurs maux bah
écoutez j'ai eu à se taper dessus cette
pauvre débile à el massa agacé pour
reconnaître que quand elle fait des
bêtises ou quand on fait un truc que je
trouve aberrant parce qu'elle est
supposée être un exemple qu elle est
suivie par beaucoup de personnes je vois
là je m'énerve
là je reconnais que l a fait un don elle
a donné de l'argent après que que que
brigitte macro les apnées alors que
c'est une influence aussi ça plutôt bien
et le fait qu'elle les films et voilà
c'est normal on aurait tous fait pareil
moi ce que je retiens c'est qu'elle a
fait un don à la donner de l'argent et
encore une fois les gens qui donnent ça
m'insupporte quand on les critique et
concéda et paris l'ont fait pour l'image
perpignan est la filer du fric elle à
filer du fric et dont elle a été appelée
ça sera bien utilisé et je trouve que
brigitte macro accompli quelque chose
une des premières marques ont pris le
rôle de ces gamines de ces jeunes de ses
influences euse justement sur d'autres
jeunes et chose que c'est pas la
première fois qu'elle fait ça est ce
qu'elle est l'une des premières dames
première dame avoir compris justement le
rôle des influenceurs